hey guys welcome back to another live
session by simply lawn today I walk you
through the responsibilities and skills
required to become an RBA developer now
I'll also provide some tips to build a
strong profile and a resuming to kick
start your RPE career all right so I see
a few people joining in I also welcome
all the viewers participating from
Facebook as well
and not to forget there's going to be a
quiz at the end of the session so stay
tuned for that one lucky winner will get
an Amazon voucher
so let's wait for a while for the people
to join in
you
so I see quite a few of you are joined
so welcome again and today's topic is
going to be how to become an RPA
developer so without further delay I
think we should begin
first let's understand who an RPA
developer is now generally speaking an
RPA developer is someone who works
cross-functionally with business
operations and business analysts to
create an optimized workflow processes
now however this is a relatively new
career path and many organizations
formal titles for RP developers dipper
now other similar positions may use
titles like process designer or
automation architect but no matter the
title the role of a successful RPE
developer requires specific skills and
best practices like documentation and
planning now in order to automate a
business process and RP developer will
be required to create workflow diagrams
and strategically document the process
prior to implementation now he may also
be responsible for testing and bug fixes
so coding skills are also important
now in order to become a successful RP
developer you must have the ability to
navigate through appropriate
technologies such as UI path or
automation anywhere
however there are a few prerequisites to
become an RPA developer well it's not
very hard but a little prep is necessary
so let's go through them one by one
first up is to teach a planning now
planning is a critical phase in any
development lifecycle the RP developer
regardless of the designation should
possess the aptitude to ensure strategic
planning strategic planning basically
includes design development and
implementation of RP systems this also
helps streamline the entire business to
optimize their efficiency next up is
analytical skills now again as the name
suggests it's crucial to analyze the
information and make decisions to
maximize your efficiency right now these
are skills that one develops when
they're exposed to it so over a period
of time you're going to develop these
skills not to worry about it now next up
is problem-solving skills now these
skills are again crucial to predict any
potential outages and equip the entire
unit to overcome any unforeseen
interruptions from the business
perspective as well
problem-solving skills play a
significant role in ensuring smooth
conduction of tasks experienced in
programming languages like C C++ C 5l
Ruby Java is also crucial
next up is hands-on experience on RP
tools and cognitive platforms like blue
prism optimation anywhere redwood open
span etc now other general skills
include communication skills as well now
this is pivotal for any organization and
the developer should be outspoken and
should articulate new ideas
let's look at the rollout phases
supporting existing processes and
implementing change requirements I
successfully managing any sort of issues
so if you are aspiring to become an RPA
developer then these are some of the job
responsibilities that you will have to
readily take out
if you're still wondering if this field
has scope for development in the coming
years let me clarify it for you so let's
go ahead and look at the RP growth
projections and sanity according to
Gartner robotic process automation
software grew up by 63% in 2018 making
it the fastest growing segment of the
global enterprise software market now
the growth curve has also been steadily
increasing since 2016 and continuous
beyond 2020 number is also predicted
that are up to nine percent of the
globally in pieces before and Accenture
among others
look at them one by one first up is to
choose your RPE platforms now all our v8
tools have graphical user interface or
GUI eyes but it's really helpful to
understand the underlying technology now
this comes in extremely handy when the
developer has to create more complex say
personalized or advanced BOTS so if you
are a Python developer then you can
start off by working with Argos labs so
this allows the developers to build
plugins with almost no effort from the
existing Python code so if you're a
Python developer then you can start off
by working with Argos labs
now this really allows developers to
build plugins with literally no effort
and if you're a.net developer then you
can start off with UI path or automation
anywheres community additions so if
you're a Java developer then you can
start off with automation anywhere and
if you are a developer with no
experience then you can begin with any
of the leading or pay providers
now tip number two is to start building
there are plenty of free materials and
guides to help you begin your RP a
journey so some of the famous or
well-known RP tools are blue prism work
fusion uipath automation anywhere etc so
just start working on them
tip number three is build your github
repository
no matter how small or simple you think
your project is go ahead and put it on
your github repository this totally adds
credibility to your profile even if
you're attending interviews one located
github repository is going to make them
realize how good of a developer you are
tip number four is to take up
freelancing projects now again to start
off you can pick up see non-paid or even
low paid projects some of the websites
that you could look up are up work
freelancer tool and so people per are
so tip number five is to start a blog
now having your own blog will add
credibility to your profile no matter
how less you've worked on any projects
you can go ahead and type in all the
information you want the tutors can also
have a glance at your profile you're
definitely going to get some extra
points for this
tip number six is to ensure you update
your resume and profile now keep your
resume and profiles updated on all job
portals like LinkedIn indeed Simply
Hired and monster so these were some
simple tips to help you become an RPA
developer there are several RPE courses
that you can take up but if you're
looking for a well curated concise
syllabus then you can head to our
official website and type in RBA so
let's do that you can go ahead and
search for RP now a list of courses will
appear and depending on your requirement
you can go ahead and choose the
appropriate one you can also go through
the overview to understand what's
covered in the course
all right then quiz time
so here is a simple true or false
question filled processing of customer
complaints can be automated using RPE
true or false write down your answers in
the comment section below or the chat
section and one lucky winner will win an
Amazon voucher I let it stay on the
screen for a while
you
go ahead and immediately type in your
answers
you
alright then with that we've come to an
end of this session if you found it
interesting make sure to like and share
the video also make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update we'll come back
with another live session soon until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
you